good morning John who the heck are you
who the heck am i how do I Know Who I am
do other people know who I am do other
people have different ideas of who I am
are those ideas close together or far
apart and what is more made than me and
their heads are than me and mine and
when I go to sleep at night and lose
consciousness for eight hours and wake
up am I still the same me that I was
when I went to bed Who am I hi my name
is Hank green I'm a heterosexual white
sis male I'm a Taurus and an ENFP I'm a
Montana non-american a book lover I
don't have any tattoos and I think that
climate change is the greatest challenge
that humanity has ever faced I'm an
entrepreneur a youtuber a slither claw
and I am divergent I once took a
BuzzFeed quiz to tell me what youtuber I
was in which I was one of the options
and I came up you guessed it Miranda
sings
thanks for the identity crisis BuzzFeed
I'm now 35 and based on what I thought
about 35 year olds when I was 25 and
when I was 15 I should know who the
Frick I am nevertheless I don't I can
describe myself all day long I could
take personality tests that validate my
behavior until the cows have baby cows
and then those baby cows have their own
baby cows and those third generation
cows finally come home but that won't
change the fact that my self is just a
story that I tell to myself that is just
like any other story subjective and
incomplete and at least a little bit of
a lie I got my way of seeing the world I
got my values I got the stuff that I
care about the people I care about all
those things they're important they're
real where did they come from
certainly not things that I was born
with I am me right now I have not always
been this me throughout my life Who I am
has been largely dependent upon what
people expect of me there's a truly
weird & unexplained link between bad
eyesight and intelligence one of the
theories that explains this in my
favorite is that kids who wear glasses
look smarter to their peers and to their
parents to their teachers and those
people then expect them to be smart and
then those kids are smart they just
fulfill those expectations and become
smart it's certainly well known that the
belief that a child is intelligent will
result in that child becoming more
intelligent even if the original belief
was falsely planted there so like now I
have a bunch of people who watch me make
videos and they respect me and entrust
me so I try to become a person worthy of
that trust and respect but not all
the time sometimes I'm down to clown
sometimes I'm introspective and I just
want to stare at the wall sing
I crave consistency in myself but myself
denies me that simplicity so we look to
books and BuzzFeed quizzes and
personality tests and horoscopes to tell
us who we might be to see what others
might think to tell us that we are doing
a good job of becoming the kind of
person we want to be and to tell us that
it's okay to be the kind of person that
you are but all of these things are such
pale reflections of the indescribably
weird and complex thing that is the cell
identity is important to try to define
but there isn't some perfect Platonic
ideal of what you is buried beneath all
of the gunk figuring out who you are at
least at this particular moment is all
about trying to tease out which bits are
you trying to fulfill other people's
expectations for your whole life bits
you want to change to make yourself
better and what bits you cherish as
vital to your unis people who are like
be yourself and they expect that to mean
something not advice that's an
existential crisis waiting gap these
tools that we use to help us define
ourselves to help us figure out who we
are they are fine as tools but they are
not walls to box ourselves in which you
will wake up one day and you will not be
the you you once were or not will keep
happening to you until you die which is
kind of wonderful I live life as just
one person when you can be so many
different people a little scarier
perhaps but as with a lot of things that
scare me turns out also pretty fun John
I'll see you on Tuesday